I usually don't leave the house past 8:00 o'clock,
but we're going to the icons party,
so I decided to make an exception.
Lucky got me sick,
so I made him run and get me all the things to hopefully
make me survive the night.
At around four PM, three hours before the event,
Marty came over to do my hair.
The amount of gel and hairspray we used for this hair
was almost criminal, but it didn't go anywhere all night long,
so that's all that mattered.
And I got started on doing my makeup.
Kind of went with a variation of my everyday makeup
since that's pretty much all I know how to do.
We were about 30 minutes out from leaving.
My stylist came over
and we decided on the jewelry and got me into the dress.
This was a two man job. The corset underneath was so tight,
but we made it work. Right as we were getting this on,
whimsy got hungry, so I nursed her and then put the older two to bed.
Lucky's luck arrived 10 minutes before we had to leave.
But lucky was so calm about it.
Said he was gonna be ready in two minutes.
Right after we got me dressed,
which didn't end up being two minutes,
we eventually made it into the car and over to the event.
I loved hanging out with all the people
and chatting to internet friends that I hadn't met before.
As soon As my ankles felt like they were about to snap,
I knew it was time to head home.